all right
um welcome to the ddk
seminar everyone before we start
let's go over some rules and logistics
uh first of all
please view yourself during the talk
unless you have questions
if you have questions and you are
welcome to commute and ask
otherwise please use chat room to post
your questions
so that we can write them in chinese
lesson at the end
second today's dps seminar is
open to external audiences no classified
discussion is allowed so i tell
finally the talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in ll now youtube channel
um that's about it now let me introduce
our speaker today it is an honor to host
water diaria who is a principal
member of the technical as sandia
national laboratories
actually across the street from us
where she works since 2014 she is
of the computational science and
analysis group
at the california site she obtained
her master's degree in
engineering at polit polytechnico
of milano under the supervision of
professor watervonnie
she obtained her phd in applied
mathematics
at emory university under the
supervision of professor
beneziani here she
worked on optimal control in cfd for
cardiovascular applications she was a
postdoctoral fellow at florida state
university which
worked with who's
guns burger on optimization for
non-local
and fractional models she's an associate
editor of sisk a
advances in continuous and discrete
models
and of the journal of hydrodynamics
and non-local models our interests
include non-local modeling and
simulation
optimization and optimal control and
scientific
machine learning today mata will talk
about data-driven learning of non-local
models
reaching skills and design of new neural
networks
which is very very interesting topic
please enjoy and expecting
to talk now without further ado let me
pass the button to the matter
by asking one random question it's
useful today's random question
is what would you rather throw away
either love or for my money
but again what's your what
would you rather throw away a law of
woman oh money
certainly of course right yes
okay thank you
thanks a lot um thanks a lot for having
me
thanks for introducing me uh it's really
a pleasure to
to present uh in this seminar series uh
so as it was mentioned this talk is
gonna be
about data driven learning techniques
for no local equations
the research that you're going to see
today is partially supported by the ldrd
program at sandia
and by films which is which stands for
physics-informed learning machines
and is the oe oscar mimics center
pi by george karnadakis
this is a brief outline of my talk it's
going to be organized in two parts
first i will introduce an operator
learning
algorithm for no local equations that
we're going to use to address
challenges in homogenization
and in particular i will focus on
designing
optimal surrogates for molecular
dynamics displacements
then there's going to be a second part
where some of the tools
that were introduced in the first part
are going to be used
to design optimal architectures for no
local
for neural networks and we're going to
refer to these as non-local kernel
networks
i will start by summarizing the
properties that we're after
and then i will show non-local kernel
networks in action
with pde learning tasks and image
classification
tasks these are the people that
contributed to this talk
uh stuart sealing at sandia labs new
mexico
stewart is the father of aerodynamics
the no local theory for for mechanics
hychen u and uau they're both from the i
uh ua is the advisor of huay chen and
wai chen
was um until a couple of uh weeks ago
uh a long term intern at san diego labs
california
all right so in the first part of my
talk
i'm gonna focus on complex systems where
the small scale dynamics the small scale
interactions
affect the global behavior and these of
course are ubiquitous in
scientific and engineering applications
in particular i'm going to focus on
systems where the effects of
heterogeneities
at the small scales need to be captured
accurately
to have reliable predictions so of
course we can use
at the very small scale we can use
classical models such as
pdes and solve for those small scales or
those um small-scale etherogeneities and
get
accurate solutions the problem is that
these simulations are are very expensive
computationally and
oftentimes cannot be afforded and so
there is the need
for new upscale models that act at
larger scales but can still capture the
effects
of small-scale behavior
the process of coarse graining or
upscaling
however heights several pitfalls and
these pitfalls may compromise the
the reliability of um of the models
um in particular when we have a
terrorist we have that the homogenized
model
has to follow a different governing law
uh and
has to have a different constitutive
property compared to the one that
applies
at a small scale so what i'm reporting
here on the right is a very simple
example where we don't even have
a super high degree of heterogeneity
this is a kind of homogeneous scent
and what happens here is that um a
simple advection diffusion equation
is accurate at the very small scale
level but as soon as we
coarse grain as soon as we look at
things at a larger scale
a simple pde is not enough anymore
and so we're facing a capability gap in
some sense
um so in the sense that homogenized
classical models
are in general not sufficient to fully
reproduce coarse-grained behavior
what we claim is that integral op and i
will i will
provide hopefully enough evidence to
support this claim
integral operators or no local operators
can provide better descriptions than
pdes because they
embed all the time and length scales in
their definition
so what i have here is the simplest
maybe example of an integral
operator where the length scale is
embedded in the domain of integration so
we have this neighborhood
of radius delta it doesn't have to be a
euclidean ball it can be pretty much
anything
and we refer to this delta as horizon
or interaction radius of course though
as
any other mathematical model integral
operators depend on parameters
uh and these parameters are in general
unknown
uh and more importantly in local
operators
in non-local operators we have that the
considerative laws
take the form of kernels or integrand
functions
and and the form of these integral
functions cannot be established a priori
and it's
hard in some sense to make to establish
a connection
between material properties or media
properties and
and these functions so today i'm going
to focus on
operators mostly on operators of this
form
these are known as non-local diffusion
operators or
this is simply an or local laplacian
so from this formula we see that
the regularity assumptions on the
solutions uh
can be relaxed because there are no
derivatives
so this is the no local counterpart of a
laplacian but
once again there are no derivatives and
so our solutions can be
very nasty they can be irregular they
they just have to be integrable
in some cases these operators depend on
kernels these kernels k
they're application dependent and they
determine the regularity properties of
the solution
and as i said already they're in general
unknown
and this is one of the biggest
challenges and open problems in no local
modeling
now this being said the local models
have
been successfully used in the literature
i mean we have many success stories
uh the use of no local operators
i'm gonna mention one uh that is
particularly
relevant in uh in this specific setting
which is homogenization
and it's the use of fractional operators
and i know that
now these operators have been mentioned
in this seminar series already
so fractional operators can be used to
model
anomalous transport in the subsurface
and they're particularly
effective in the presence of a very high
degree of heterogeneity
you can recognize here so here c is the
concentration of a pollutant in the
subsurface
this is the count the fractional
counterpart of a classical laplacian
and you can recognize the same structure
that i had in my previous slide and
the kernel k in this case is this
fractional term
so and to show you an example of how
effective these operators are
this is a paper that dates back in 2000
by benson and and this is for the
so-called male data set it's a very uh
it's a highly atherogenius
uh data set and the
solid thick line is the solution of the
fractional
model so it's called alpha stable and
it almost matches the the data the
concentration data
and and here at the bottom uh the flat
line
is uh is the standard pde the
advection division equation so the
difference is is certainly striking in
this
in this case so there are examples
of where the kernel function is known uh
and can be used
and it also has a some sort of physical
interpretation i would say
however we're interested in systems
where
the connection between the data that we
have and the kernel is not
that immediate and so this is the recipe
that we propose of course i mean there
is no need for me to
advertise the combination of machine
learning and physical laws
we know that this is a winning strategy
what we want to add
into the picture is we call it unified
calculus and it's basically
a calculus that includes the classical
calculus but also the integral calculus
so that we can give some we can get some
models that are mathematically rigorous
so what we're after are new non-local
models
or optimal non-local models that are
guaranteed to be well posed
because of the calculus and that are
physically consistent
so our working assumption is that
we can collect high-fidelity data or
perform
small-scale high-fidelity simulations um
in what
you're going to see next in the main
topic of this first part
the high fidelity is going to be
molecular dynamics but it could be dns
or we may have
exact solvers and going back to what i
said at the beginning
our goal is to find an optimal non-local
model
that at the larger scale um
basically reproduces the high fidelity
model or is as close as possible to the
high fidelity model
so the question since we decided to
describe
this operator as the local laplacian
the real goal is to find the optimal
kernel k
so i'm going to start from basically the
core technique
that i'm going to use that was
introduced last year
in this paper and then extended in
into subsequent papers
i'm going to summarize this technique in
three simple steps
and for now i'm going to start from a
scalar
unknown so from a scalar variable this
is again
the operator that you saw at the
beginning
k is our unknown and we're interested in
the elliptic equation so in the
local counterpart of a poisson equation
basically this is the residual of the
equation that we're looking at
we collect measurements these are our
high fidelity pairs of solution and
forcing function
and we build a surrogate for the kernel
in the specific case so what we have
here is a linear combination of basis
functions
in our first work we consider bernstein
polynomials
so this is the form of our kernel which
is uniquely determined by
the the coefficient cm and then we
minimize the residual so here's where
the physics comes into play uh subject
to
solvability constraints or in other
words no local theory that guarantees
that this operator once we learn k is
well posed
the outcome of course are the
coefficients that uniquely determine the
kernel
this was the first work that basically
could learn the functional form of the
kernel previous works were
were focused on learning parameters of
given functional forms for the kernel
a very important feature of this
algorithm
is that we allow the kernel to be sign
changing
so first let me say that whenever this
kernel is positive
it's much much easier to prove the well
posedness of the system associated
with this operator as soon as this
kernel can take on negative values
uh the proof of world posens is more
involved however
there are evidence there's evidence in
the literature
that sign changing kernels um
are particularly effective in describing
the
high frequency response of materials so
when we want to model material response
we'd better use um a sign changing
kernel
and we then embedded in this algorithm
uh some some no local theory developed
by the
mages and chandu that basically gave us
some
explicit sufficient conditions on the
kernel to be sign changing and to induce
a well post problem and so from now on
we always allow
the kernel to be sign changing but we
have to keep in mind that specific
conditions for what postness need to be
embedded this is the first
example of how we apply this operator
learning technique
and i'm just going to have i just have
two slides this is a simple extension
of what i just presented and we extend
that
to the vector case basically so now
we're looking at elasticity
in particular we're looking at
elasticity in bodies
whose microstructure is heterogeneous
and is periodic
so this is a 1d example this is a 2dx
sample and these are different types of
microstructure
that we considered so the point is
while with a pde and in our case we use
finite elements
we have to mash the whole thing we have
to solve for these
interfaces when we use a non-local model
what we're going to do is to put one
degree of freedom in each unit cell
so here we're just going to have one
degree of freedom
and so based on some high fidelity
measurements
which are going to come from fine grit
finite element simulations of the linear
elasticity equation
we want to learn the best kernel k
such that this model describes well
enough
uh the material behavior so now
the other example yes so sorry to
interrupt
there is a the firefox
icon and camera icon and it's
it's blocking yeah i can know it's there
i'm not sure
i can move it oh yes i can move it
okay it's on my name you know who i am
is it better
yeah great that's better yes
i i apologize i thought you were not
able to see it but
okay um so the other extension that we
have here
is uh the second derivative in time so
um now we have a hyperbolic equation
uh but the the algorithm is exactly the
same so we still minimize the residual
of the equation and in this case
and this is something that we learned uh
in uh in the subsequent papers
um it's very important to add anything
we know about the physics and
in this particular case um i'm not gonna
focus
too much on this example uh because i
want to focus more on the molecular
dynamics case
uh here we added a constraint on the
second moment
of the of the kernel um
as i already said uh the high fidelity
is given
by a finite element simulation on a
verifying grid
so i just want to show one result for
for this
uh specific topic and what i have here
is what you see in these graphs is the
acceleration
for one unit cell and i think we picked
the central
unit cell um here you see the
acceleration in x
here at the bottom the acceleration in y
and
the first column is without the
constraint the second column is with the
constraint
it's important um to point out i want to
point out that
um these simulations go beyond the
training time so we're simulating
past the training time but also we're
using different boundary conditions that
the than the ones compared to the ones
that were used for training
because we want to make sure that the
kernel
only embeds material properties and is
not
an independent of boundary conditions
forcing terms and any other
input to the problem all right so
this was an application to elasticity
but what i really want to
talk about is how we apply this
technique
uh to bridging the molecular scale and
the continuum scale
and we just submitted this paper
and i'm just waiting first on the
approval to
upload it on archive um let me give you
some background
um this is part of an ongoing ldrd
project
where we're looking at molecular
dynamics as a tool
for designing new materials but in
particular what we're interested in
is in testing materials and the goal is
to improve their reliability and
performance
um when we want to test the materials
however
we cannot use molecular dynamics we we
need continuum
models that act at larger scales
so based on what i said at the beginning
we need to upscale
md to the continuum scale when we need
to upscale and d to the continuum scale
my local models or integral models
really seem to be the
the best choice three reasons
but i in my next slide i'll make that
clearer
first they can treat discontinuities
solutions
don't have to be regular they're
compatible with the molecular scale
and they can capture multi-scale
behavior because they have bad
length scales in their definition we
have this capability gap
that i mentioned which is we need to
identify the kernel
of any local model that we want to use
and so we use our recipe we start from
md data
and then we apply our recipe where we
combine
physics local calculus and machine
learning or basically optimization
so um i'll be brief here what all i want
to say in this slide is that
when we coarse grain or upscale or
smooth
let's say molecular dynamics
displacement
we can show that the upscaled model is
a no-local equation so i'm going to
start from an assembly
of interacting particles and my goal is
to go from the particles
to a continue model we have forces
acting
between particles and forces acting on
the particles external forces
and what i'm going to do to get to my
continued model is to introduce a
smoothing function
smoothing function that has a compact
support
inside inside a ball and has some
normalization properties
and i'm going to translate all my
variables in smoothed
variables like this and then
by keeping in mind newton's law we
combine all these ingredients
and we end up with with an integral
equation
and in the paper this is this is done
way more carefully
um of course we end up with this
integral equation but
what what's what's the best f so uh our
goal now is to identify
the best constitute no local
constitutive law
i'm gonna recall the operator learning
algorithm for and i'm gonna extend it to
this
specific case uh once again the goal is
to learn
uh the best kernel k
since we we are looking at material
properties
we are going to lose we're going to look
at operators that are
a little bit more complex than the no
local laplacian
and in particular we're going to look at
the linear peridynamic solid operator
i'm going to say a little more about
this operator the important thing
here is that this operator
has in its definition material
properties such as
poisson racial and young's modulus
and it can treat um a larger a broader
spectrum of material behavior compared
to
the non-local laplacian also known as
bond-based
model 4 for mechanics
the procedure is the same we start from
nd measurements
and d displacements and we have pairs of
displacements
and external forces and we approximate
once again
the kernel with a surrogate and once
again it's a linear combination of basis
functions
however uh we are gonna slightly change
the definition of the
of the kernel in the sense that uh we're
gonna add
a fractional term if you remember what i
the the fractional operator that i
introduced at the beginning
we had a singularity in the kernel
and the singularity the intensity or the
strength of that singularity is
determined by the fractional order alpha
we notice that having a tunable
singularity really
makes the predictions more accurate
and so alpha is going to be attunable
parameters together with
the sine changing coefficients meaning
that the coefficients are allowed to
to have different signs they don't have
to be positive
for the same reasons that i explained
earlier
and then we minimize the residual and in
this case
just keep in mind that this is a more
complex operator
uh that also depends on uh the poisson
ratio
and the young's modulus and we have an
elliptic equation because
uh even though md is in time we're just
going to look at the last
snapshot so what we're going to minimize
is an elliptic equation
so viability constraints in this case
are definitely
they're way more involved and the reason
is
that the linear peridynamic solid model
is a much more complex model
compared to the classica no local
laplacian
and there is no theory in the literature
for weld postness of sine changing
kernels and so what we did
in our case was simply uh to and i'm
just gonna describe this in words
because the
i don't want to get into the theorem but
we're going to prescribe
discrete imp subconditions for this
system
and those are going to be our
solvability constraint
for the operator regression algorithm
and this is just a summary of what i
just said but once again i don't think
this
uh this is super relevant the important
thing is that we still have
some solvability constraints coming from
the local theory that are going to
guarantee
that even though our kernel is sign
changing we're going to have a
well-posed problem
now let me describe a little bit
the material that we are considering and
the data set that we are considering
we are looking at a single layer
graphene
graphene is a very resistant material
characterized by
a negative poisson ratio this is an
example
of a training sample that that we use
this is generated with their tears of
potential
um the sewer sealing in our team uh
took care of the md simulations uh these
are at fixed
temperature and we tried uh we tested
both
zero temperature so a perfect crystal
and uh 300k temperature
and the variability in the training data
set is given by
the the loading basically by the forcing
term
and they all look uh they're all
different but they all look pretty much
like this of course we want to make sure
that
the optimal kernel gives good results
even when tested
uh in circumstances that are different
from the ones that were used for
training
and so we pick a different a different
loading
and we generate new samples that we're
going to use for validation
and i have other samples and i'm going
to talk about them later
this is just to give you an idea of the
outcome of this algorithm
the kernels very often have this
structure
um this is the kernel as a function
of the distance uh so the kernel is
radial
so we are only reporting uh the kernel
as a function of the distance and as you
can see
uh it's it's negative and this is really
important
i don't have the results in this
presentation but
uh if we don't allow the kernel to be
sign changing
we definitely do not get accurate
solutions so this is really important
these are the optimal young's modulus
poisson
ratio and the the good news is that it's
consistent with
experiments in the theory in the
literature
and here i just want to say a couple of
um
just spend a couple of words on how we
find the optimal parameters
so this is far from being a
sophisticated by level optimization
technique
but basically what we're doing here is
to
have an outer optimization loop where
we find the best horizon that determines
the extent
of the no local interactions and the
best number of basis functions
um so the number of bursting polynomials
that we're gonna use
um and in the inner loop we find the
coefficients
uh of the kernel the young's modulus
poisson ratio
and the fractional order the metrics of
accuracy
that we're going to use are either the
evaluation of the residual of the
equation
and this is the one over the training
set or the accuracy
of the solution so this is the
our operator with the optimal kernel and
we compare it with the data that we have
again over the training set same
measures can be defined
for the sampling set and here um i
highlighting the the selections
basically
of the best m and delta uh at different
temperatures
so this is my last example uh
when it comes to md and what we do here
i'm just reporting for reference an
example of training
sample that we used um
the testing sample in this case not only
has a different forcing
uh so here the loading so these f's are
supposed to be these
apologies so these are b's the forcing
term is zero
uh inside the domain and it's not zero
outside the domain
and the geometry is completely different
which is probably the most
striking difference between the two
samples so
this is a comparison uh between the
the data process data and our solution
which is nine percent accurate
and and here we use the kernel that was
uh
generated by using this type of training
samples and
and i think what this example is showing
is that uh the kernel truly embeds only
the material properties clearly
it wouldn't work as well if with
something that
is not graffiti so the kernel represents
graphene
in some sense so
i can basically summarize this first
part of the talk
in what i just said in my last slide
about transfer learning
the optimal no local model embeds
material properties
and the optimal kernel is able to
work well in some things that are i
would say substantially different
uh than the ones used in the in the
training
uh phase um something that i didn't show
but it's uh that is in the preprint and
that we are still working on
is a hybrid technique to make sure that
the kernel is also resolution
independent so
it doesn't matter whether we use the
kernel
on the same grid you used for training
or on a different grid
we're still going to get something that
is accurate and the key
is the fact that we're looking at a
continuous model
right now we're working on damage which
is a much more complicated problem
it requires different models different
settings
and certainly different constraints so
this is probably going to take us a
while
to conclude this part on homogenization
i just want to mention that
the same technique was used for
wave propagation through heterogeneous
materials so here instead of using a
wave a classical wave equation we use a
non-local wave equation to describe
propagation through heterogeneous
materials and here what really made the
difference are some physics constraint
on the group wave velocity
how many minutes do i have
are you still there sorry my
computer is no no no no
um i mean you you have you have plenty
of time
right now but um yeah i mean okay okay
yeah yeah just to have an idea just to
have an idea
um so this is not completely
disconnected to
what i i just presented and actually in
this second part
i want to i want to show you how we use
these kernel learning tools
to develop um optimal kernel optimal
neural network architectures
we refer to them as no local kernel
networks because
um because we are learning kernels in
some sense
and i just want to add that uh there is
a person that
at tian gao that i didn't uh mention at
the beginning but that contributed to
to this work so um
since this is quite a jump i'm gonna
pause for a second
and uh let's forget for a second about
um non-local operators and i'm going to
give you some context
uh we're looking at neural networks and
in particular i want to focus on
resnets and i'm reporting here maybe
the simplest form of a resnet
update uh we have the increment
h is the value at every layer of the
neural network
t represents uh the layer and we have
the usual
um a fine transformation uh within the
activation function that defines the
increment
so the reason why i have a delta t here
is because
uh it's um
well known by now that we can look at
resonance as euler discretizations and
if we divide
this equality by delta t we recognize an
euler discretization and as we
let the delta t go to zero we end up
with
an ordinary differential equation and
that's why
these networks are referred to as neural
odes
so what we like about neural ods is that
they're continuous uh i mean we're
mathematicians
so we we like seeing equations and we
like using
rigorous analysis
and establish numerical techniques
and we can use standard optimization
techniques developed for
for odes so these are features that we
like
about this continue model and that we
would like
to keep in our network
we're still going to work with resnet
but i'm going to add
another feature on top of continuity and
interpretability uh
as a as an ode another feature that we
would like to have
so let me mention why we want this
feature
so as in the previous part of the
presentation we have material design and
testing in mind
and in particular we're thinking of
image classification in the context of
materials and
image classification can be used for
detecting anomalies uh detecting uh
signatures of failure and and things and
things like this
so with the image classification task
in mind we're looking at the we we would
like to have a network that is
resolution independent
and also since we know that networks
like convolutional neural networks or
graph neural networks that
take into account um long-range
interactions in the feature space
meaning
in the node space uh we would also like
to have that feature so long range
interactions
in the in the nodes in the set of nodes
this is a cartoon of what i just said
and
being resolution independent is
something that can be achieved by making
the set of notes a continuum
continuum set and
and these kind of screens no local
models in some sense
um so what we're gonna do uh instead of
having the
f uh that i had in my previous slide for
the resnet
we're gonna use an integral operator
um clearly we're we're not the first
people uh
that uh we're not the first one to look
at
neural networks with the presence of an
integral operator
um so i'm gonna recall two
important techniques to important
architectures in the literature
and i'm going to start from them to
design our own architecture
so this is the graph kernel network
introduced by lee
andrew stewart at caltech gave several
talks about
this type of approach so here we have an
original like a
the resnet block and
what we have here is that uh so this is
an
increment uh and this is how it's
defined d
is the set of nodes so it's a continuous
set of nodes
x is the variable that determines the
node
and t is the layer in some sense in this
interpretation
uh k is a is a kernel b
is the input so the kernel may even
depend on the input um
it doesn't necessarily so in some of
their tests it doesn't
um and k is itself
a network so k is a shallow neural
network that can be learned
while learning all the other parameters
and in particular the parameters that
can be learned
are r c and the weights and biases of
this
of this network so these are some
good and bad points of this network
unless sigma is the identity
it's hard to establish a direct
connection between
this network update and a pde or an ode
another bad point is that in the limit
of deep layers
this network may become unstable or at
least
the accuracy stagnates what's nice is
that
it's it's very descriptive because k is
not fixed
k is something that we learn as we go uh
and another important thing which is one
of the things that we like the most
about this network is that optimal
parameters are resolution independent
because we are at the continuous level
then we have another network that is
also
uh no local at the discrete level in
some sense
so in this case this kernel this network
is discrete so it's not
a continuous it's not defined as a
continuous update
um what we have here is that
the the increment is defined as
once again no local interactions so here
we have a kernel
that connects two nodes um and what we
have here is that this kernel is fixed
i'm reporting the continuous counter
part of this network
because it's important to understand the
connections between the two
so in this paper they didn't look at the
continuous network they didn't implement
the continuous network but they
simply looked at the discrete one so in
this case
uh it's harder it's you cannot really
handle different resolutions because
you're looking at
a discrete network k is fixed so it's
it's probably less descriptive than than
the previous one
but it's stable as the number of layers
increases and
what makes it stable is the presence of
this
uh of this extra term the h h
j i'm sorry the h i so it's the
difference
that makes it stable uh and i'm gonna
say more about this and i'm gonna say
why
this becomes stable and also it can be
analyzed as
a discrete no local equation because
this is truly the discretization of a
non-local laplacian
just the an additional good property of
the bottom one
is that as opposed to the previous one
we can handle different resolutions
because it's formulated at a continuous
level
so now let me get to our network where
we try to combine the good aspects of
both
uh and so we have so we have the network
update here and uh this network
network update is defined with an
integral operator
where we have the difference so we're
trying to mimic
um this network so the one that is
stable
um and we're adding some uh what what
we're going to call
reaction terms and some forcing terms
also
uh k is going to be a shallow neural
network and r is going to be a neural
network to
increase the descriptive power of of
this network but
note that both the kernel and r are not
time dependent as i said earlier
these the set is the continuum set of
nodes
at times we will consider the whole set
of nodes but sometimes we will just
consider
a ball surrounding a point just for
efficiency purposes
this is a summary uh for our network
uh we're gonna use it on both pde
learning tasks which is what
graph kernel networks were developed for
and image classification which is what
the non-local networks were designed for
the important feature that we want is
being resolution independent and being
stable in the limit of deep networks
and this is this is possible because we
can show that the network is stable
together with the stability of in the
limit of deep
networks um i want to introduce
uh this technique that we use uh and i'm
gonna show you some results right away
because i'm not gonna go over this
specific technique we use a shallow to
deep
training which means that we we can
initialize
deeper and nip and deeper networks by
using the result coming from
the more shallow network and this is
possible in our specific case because
our uh our networks here
our network parameters do not depend on
time
but the shallow to deep training can be
done for
any stable network just by interpolating
the optimal parameters over
the layers and by using them as initial
guesses and and this is exactly what we
did when we have two layers
we have basically random initialization
for both and what we do as we
increase the number of layers is to use
the optimal solution
at the previous number of layers as
initialization and as you can see
um the training is uh as much faster we
start from a much lower
lost loss value this is the training
loss
all right um just a one word on
stability
um i'm going to consider the scalar case
so that
there's really a resemblance with what i
presented in the previous part of my
talk
so what you can recognize here is a
local laplacian
and if we call this lk as i did in the
previous part of my talk and we divide
everything by delta t
here we have an euler discretization
and a local diffusion a reaction term
and a force in term
and as we let delta t go to zero
we have a parabolic non-local equation
so this is a diffuse and no local
diffusion equation
and we can use the unified or non-local
calculus to analyze it
and by using the no local calculus we
can find sufficient conditions
such that this is stable and and this is
basically why
uh we can guarantee stability
all right um i don't have a lot of
examples so i'll i'll try to
i think i'm going over time um so
first we consider pde learning in this
specific case we pick
exactly the same tests that were in the
graph kernel network paper so we have a
pde
where the differential operator is
characterized by a
by parameter b which is the input
and here's our pde the goal
is given some training set b
f and u we want to learn a map
from the input to the output that is
resolution independent so
it's independent of the discretization
side this is just a technicality on how
we set the initial and last layer
of the network the proof of concept
result is poisson's equation
where the operator is the second
derivative uh
and uh and b the the coefficient of
the operator is one this is how we
generate solutions we're basically using
manufactured solutions
and here's a comparison in terms of
training error and testing error between
graph kernel networks and
no local kernel networks and we are
observing exactly what was predicted by
the theory which is the graph kernel
network
seem to stagnate as we increase the
number of layers so each column
indicates the number of layers and we
have both the
train and test error and as you can see
instead the graph kernel network sorry
the no local kernel network
is is stable to
further confirm the stability we also
compute the eigenvalues of the operator
which show the mean the minimum and
maximum
as a function of the layers the number
of layers
which confirm the coercivity of this
operator which guarantees stability
we tested it on darcy's flow to the
darcy's flow uh in this case the input
is the permeability
uh which is a two value uh piecewise
constant function which is generated
uh randomly and once again we do the
same test and this is also in the graph
kernel network paper
we consider uh different
different resolutions and different
number of layers
and we observe the same thing while
graph kernel networks
stagnate our network keeps
improving and uh and this confirms once
again stability
but here's another test that shows uh
the
fact uh that this network is resolution
independent
uh and what we have here is so the first
s
is the resolution with during training
and the second
as prime is the resolution for testing
and
while uh in the for low layers we see
that graph kernel networks
do i would say almost an equally good
job they're actually
better in the limit of the players
we definitely do a better job with the
same resolution and with the
cross-resolution test
n a by the way uh just means that we
didn't have enough memory and
we had to give up
all right i'm just going to conclude
with image classification
i truly have two slides uh these are the
data sets that we consider uh the first
one was uh much
simpler to train and what we have here
is a comparison with the
with cnn no local neural networks
uh the discrete ones and our network and
uh
while uh so here we have
images um we here we train on find
images here we train on course images
and we validate either on fine or on
course and same here
so while cnns are
are always the most accurate on the same
resolution in terms of validation
they they definitely do not they don't
do a good job
in cross-resolution tasks while no local
kernel networks
uh do so here block just means layers
um in in the non-local network
community they're apparently called
blocks and r simply means that we don't
look at the whole set of nodes but we
only take the integral
over a ball of radius 3.
and these are the results for the cipher
data set and here we compare cnn once
again with
the non-local neural network and then
the local kernel network
uh same resolution finite resolution
coarser resolution and
it looks like this network always gives
better results all right i think i i
talked for too long
so um i'm gonna thank you for for your
attention for staying with me until now
and i'm happy to to take any questions
thank you thank you so much maka for
interesting talk and wonderful talk
it was very educational for me because i
was not
you know familiar with the local
formulation at all but it was it was
a good exposure for me okay let's have a
q a sessions um
okay let me look at the
chat room i do see a question from
garvin
he's asking thanks mata can you explain
the shallow to deep training again
is there a reference for that procedure
yes absolutely uh i should have put it
actually it's a work
by uh aldad haber and uh
lars rototto it's about
multi-dimensional
no multi-scale convolutional neural
networks
uh i'll make sure i i send i send the
reference for this
so basically here sorry probably went
too fast on this
what we can do is learn the optimal
parameters
for a first number of layers
let's say we learn the optimal
parameters when we have four layers
and then once we get to convergence we
take the optimal parameters and we use
them we use that solution
as an initial guess for the next
training
with eight layers so in our case
this technique is incredibly easy simply
because
our kernels our kernel and
r do not depend on time so
the layers represent the time so for us
we can simply
pick the optimal solution and stick it
in there and
there's no problem however when you have
uh
optimal parameters that depend on time
that means that when you train on four
layers
you're gonna have optimal parameters for
four layers but
if your network is stable what you can
do is to take
those four layer parameter parameters
and interpolate them and project them on
the eight layers
and so you have a new initial guest that
comes from interpolating or evaluating
your four optimal parameters on the
eight layers
network and you use that as an initial
guess
and your loss function is definitely to
start from a much lower
value and training is is much easier is
much faster
thank you thank you um so i i don't know
i had a related question about that so
when you increase the number of layers
from going you know going from you know
shallow to deep
you reduce the number of hidden nodes
and when you increase the
layers how if i keep the number of nodes
the same
is that is that the question yes
oh you do that but you
um you don't have to right because it's
all continuous
so if you want to change it you can
so if let's say you feel like you cannot
afford it
uh you cannot afford the same number
that you had before you you could change
it
in principle we didn't but um
there is nothing that that stops you
from doing that
yeah okay so so the other numerical
numerical example needs to be
done
is it better i just removed my
headphones oh i see
um i'm here
yeah i'm hearing the ankle
is it better now sometimes hello
yeah yeah i don't hear it anymore okay
that's great surprise
is there any other questions okay well i
i have
i have a couple of mores
yeah this talk is recorded and yeah
whenever it is available i will but
everyone knows
okay so for the first part of the talk
um
you know you mentioned that you are
aiming for the application
where conor functions are not known in
non-local formulation right yeah and
only the data is available
right right so so what are those
applications is the paradigms you have
shown
in the presentation yeah so we use um
so peridynamics was was not designed
for for molecular dynamics right so
we are using a peridynamic model that is
usually
used for modeling fracture uh
in some sense but we we found
that this is at least in this case
is a good model to describe
coarse-grained
molecular dynamics displacements um
this model uh is not going to work with
damage
we have to change this model we have to
embed
a damage a damage tracking function
so that's that's what we're working on
right now um
now i started by mentioning the
subsurface
example so this is an example where the
kernel is given
however i mean it's given people are you
have been using this kernel for for
years
however fractional models are incredibly
expensive
and sometimes they you know
you may not want to go with this form
you may want to go with for example
an exponent that depends on x and so the
learning problem comes back
what's the best not only what's the best
s as a scalar but what's
uh or as a constant but what's the best
s
of x so function that uh that gives you
the
the order uh but even
you know even going beyond this uh we
are now looking at
not using fractional operators so what
we're working on now is to find because
they're really expensive because you're
you have to integrate over infinite
domains and definitely
fractional discretization has made like
gigantic
steps forward but this is still
expensive i mean you still have
an infinite domain so what we're looking
at is
truncated kernels so we want to reduce
this domain of integration
but as soon as you do that you may lose
something and so you have to compensate
and so that means that you have to find
a better kernel
and so you have we're after an optimal
kernel for
for anomalous transport i see
so even even for the application where
the kernel is known
um the application of funnel can be very
expensive so
yeah alternative might be that thankful
okay um
is is the you know
all the examples seems to be uh the
elliptic
equations by the way it can can it be
applied to the hype probably yeah yeah
yeah i i didn't want to
use too much of your time but uh so in
the one
in so i showed one at the beginning
uh so this is uh time dependent
uh it's a no local counterpart of
elasticity
and here we have weight propagation
and the equation is a no local wave
equation
so basically you have second derivative
in time
and of course it's it's more expensive
because you're
in your loss function you have to
consider all the
all the time steps in particular what
made it what made this really expensive
was that
minimizing the residual of the equation
was not good enough
we were not getting good results
and so what we had to do here was to go
back to
the counterpart of pd constrained
optimization basically where we minimize
the difference between data
and displacement subject to the no local
wave equation
um it it performs well
it's more expensive than the one that i
presented previously
but the idea is the same bursting
polynomials for the kernel
and the loss function now has time data
as well
it's a time series as well a
let's data okay so um
my another question is for the molecular
dynamic
uh the problems you know uh the one of
the advantages of
you using the non-local method was um
you can introduce the
you know this continuous uh the basis
for the
kernel for example yeah
but it's also that the computational
saving you reduce the number of degrees
of freedom
uh by a lot because your your
local grid is much coarser than md
so the number of degrees of freedom
really cut
right right so regarding that my first
question
is um you know so in in some sense
i mean you you've been using the
bernstein basis function for the kernel
all the time yes technically you could
use
other discontinuous basis function right
absolutely
absolutely yeah you can use the i can
tell you why uh we use them uh
especially in our first work uh we
wanted to do analysis and these are
uh compactly supported uh positive
functions
and dealing with improving stuff when
you have a positive function when you
know the sign of your function
is much much easier so that's
the main reason uh for which we pick
them but
um as long as you make sure
uh that you prescribe uh the good
constraints meaning well-posedness
constraint you can even put a neural
network there
but while so in our very first work
uh we had the convex problem i mean it
was a nice with burn steam polynomials
it was a very nice problem
as soon as you put a neural network
it's a mess right proving things and
even the optimization so our i guess our
approach is if we don't need it we don't
use it
um yeah i totally agree
it's just really easy let's put it this
way no i mean i'm joking
it's just if you get uh results that are
accurate enough
there's no need to make the problem more
complex yeah
yeah i i i well you said
you're joking but i'm in some sense i'm
not joking um
you know i'm i'm into i'm in the in the
community of the
i'm you know i'm actively doing the
research on
the surrogate modeling or we just do the
modeling there are a lot of neural
network
uh you know approach tries to you know
the building the sergey model in there
but if
i mean you could be representability
because it's it's
it's it's introducing nonlinear
representation of the solution
um compared to the traditional you know
linear subspace
solution representation but but it's a
theory
in theory it's not supported richly
you know those neural network thingy and
also
the training of those neural net is
exactly yeah it's a lot more expensive
and a lot more violent
has to be done absolutely while the
linear soft space
this you know the social representation
it's
it's theory it's it's backed by a theory
very vigorously and and also the
training is very
cheap um and my philosophy also
in alignment with universe if
the lineage of this and the simpler
method works well and
yeah do not move on to the neural net
exactly
exactly all right
okay so my next question is um you know
the
dynamics how the data how is the data
generated it's it's generated by the
simulation yeah it's a an md
uh well it's um the code is is a sandia
code
which actually i believe is not uh like
it's a it's a call developed developed
initially for peridynamics so for no
local
uh but that was adapted to md uh
and uh we pick a specific um potential
for
md the their subpotential and
these are just plain md md simulations
uh stewart ceiling performed them
[Music]
okay uh um thank you thank you so much
mata
for answering thank you for having me
uh well um i don't see any more
questions
from the chat room so i'm assuming that
no
questions
yeah don't be shy though if you do have
a question please
speak if not
we will get up here thank you so much
for the wonderful talk and thanks a lot
for having me
it was a pleasure yeah it was wonderful
i mean
it's i mean today is the day i will be
more interested in local fantastic
fantastic i'm really happy to hear that
yeah yeah
and and for everyone else i hope this
is you know the initialization of the
future collaboration with the matter
and mata is doing wonderful work so
thank you if there is a chance for the
collaboration that that will be
awesome yeah we're always very open
for collaboration wonderful
with that okay thank you again um
thank you thank you everyone else who
joined us
and i believe the next ddps seminar is
done again next week so please stay
tuned for the
uh announcements okay thank you thank
you mother and thank you everyone
bye okay all right
you